was there anything that you learned
about this world that you maybe didn't
particularly know before
that excited you it's just even like how
being a storm trooper is incredibly
uncomfortable
does your character think that he is a
villain because he is you know the
antagonist of the show or does he think
that he is out there doing what he
believes is right and that he's actually
more of a hero
i've been saying this all along man
cyril absolutely believes he's the hero
of his own story
andrea how are you today hi i'm good how
are you
i'm doing fantastic i must say i truly
did love andor the few episodes i saw
i loved your character one thing i
really loved was the mystery and
intensity surrounding your character
with that mystery i was kind of curious
um with all of the
seemingly past history with cassian
is she helping cassian because of their
history or does she want to take down
the empire or both
oh good god
[Laughter]
um
you know
i think she she
she helps him because he's in trouble i
think
you know whether she has
other agendas and and other
things i think this one's very specific
i think
he did something bad and needs help okay
and she sort of
rejects it and oh and then wants a piece
of it and then rejects it again
cassian why did you have to come now
um right when everything was running
smooth for big right here he comes in
and disrupts everything and
so yeah so i think she helps a friend i
think she
puts the safety of a friend before her
own and i think
that's when bix really discovers what
true bravery
means
gotcha love that and that actually kind
of you talked a little bit about her
kind of everything going smoothly for
her another question i was wondering is
does she want somewhat of a normal life
and you know she has a relationship with
tim but cassie keeps coming around is
she trying to live a normal life
i think she is i think she's desperately
wanting to live a normal life and
i think i think there's things around
her that are not
ignoring and she wants to so bad
but she can't i think it goes beyond her
i think bix is more class it's pretty
pretty straightforward um
she wants this for herself hence why
she's in a relationship with tim who
which probably
you can tell that she really cares for
him but
it's not the person for her
um
and
and you see when casting comes in all of
a sudden she like comes to
life in a way she's right you know
everything starts
you know lighting up um
yeah
i love that it's kind of the thing where
it's like you know this is easy
but kind of bland but this over here is
a little bit hard but it's like exciting
and invigorating and yeah yeah that's
kind of what that is in the character
and it's at her own detriment too you're
like girl get together don't do it but
but you know i think there's there's a
lot of things happening in the galaxy
that that
that kind of
help her make that decision
sure that makes sense with everything
going on kyle how are you doing today
nice to meet you i'm doing great warren
how are you man i'm fantastic
i just want to say truly i really love
your character in the show
because this show to me i want it to be
very intense and your character really
really brings that i feel especially in
some parts where like you're talking
about the other character um
you're talking about how two of your you
know people have been killed
and he says it's outrageous and you're
like exactly i was like ooh the
conviction in that part was uh just
bravo but so my question is my first one
that i really want to know is your
character is faced with
something that i think a lot of people
in real life might be faced with your
superior tells you to do something but
you're kind of conflicted because
internally you want to do what's right
and you ultimately make a decision so
i'm curious does your character think
that he is a villain because he is you
know the antagonist of the show or does
he think that he is out there doing what
he believes is right and that he's
actually more of a hero
i've been saying this all along man
cyril absolutely believes he's the hero
of his own story um
i think all these characters are that
we're exploring in in andor actually
um
everybody's got light and shade
but he's got complexity and real
humanity actually that
i i certainly haven't seen in a kind of
i think on on this level i haven't seen
it in star wars before
and um
it's certainly what attracted me to the
role is like you know this guy's doesn't
really know who he is yet
and he's trying to figure out his sense
of worth and his sense of identity
through the structure of
organization called yeah and like that's
super dangerous for somebody who's
willing to give over their life and
their ideals to
um something that has that much power
and control and he wants it to even have
even more power and control he does
yeah so i'm just curious in preparing
for this role and kind of understanding
the world of star wars was there
anything that you learned about this
world that you maybe didn't particularly
know before
that excited you
um specifically about
um
andor um
i learned i i learned a lot of things
just even like how being a storm trooper
is incredibly uncomfortable
i i all i wanted was to be a a storm
trooper like in the background just like
for one take and nobody's ever gonna
know that i was it but i just wanted to
wear it so bad just first did you do it
i didn't do it but i really really
really regret not doing it have you at
least tried on a suit
i have not oh i really there was no time
it was you know it was crazy busy for us
but i really i really i really wanted to
i kind of regret not and you know oh and
realizing that the you know creature
actors and serb troopers they're the
true heroes of this of this set and of
any star wars set they're they've been
there for
years they almost look at you like all
right hi rookie
it's number seven for me and i'm like
you know they've been in it for
years they know this world they they've
been playing different
you know
creatures for
ever
and
you know that's my respect i'm like
you're you're the boss and they said i
got it you know and it's
it's quite it's quite beautiful
that is amazing
i think that's amazing and i think the
world is really going to welcome you as
you say the rookie coming in i think
they're going to love uh big saying
they're going to love your portrayal of
her so that's that was actually one of
my questions to follow up with was does
he want to climb the ranks of the empire
you think he seems very patriotic very
loyal is that something he'd want to do
100
yeah i mean he's
he's definitely
like the best foot soldier they could
ever have i mean
he uh
he kind of doesn't have anything to lose
you understand where he comes from later
on in the in the series you meet his mom
you know you understand what his home
life was like
growing up and and that's something that
was like super refreshing you know i've
never seen that
before
and um
you have this macro scope of like the
huge star wars universe and then it gets
so intimate
as well and um
but he
yeah man like
he's uh
he's
he's willing to do whatever it takes
to um
get that power and get that recognition
but he he's willing to do that because
he believes it's the right thing to do
right so good question
he's got a really strong
moral core i mean
at the very beginning as you say right
like he there are two
security officers who've been murdered
and he's like well i'm an inspector like
we should investigate that right
yeah you're working with people who are
really lazy and kind of like over it and
and don't really want the empire to be
evolved because involved because they're
like well things are good man we just
hang out and have my ties and like you
know just kind of get on and right he's
like no there's like
you what cyril understands is that like
are pockets
that are
that are openings
for
potential threat
every time something is
uh let's say a security guard is
murdered or a taste of rebellion has
kind of come up like if you don't act on
that immediately if you don't send the
right message
then that can grow into something
greater
so i
think yeah i mean like
in my real life
would i would i be on cyril's side
probably not but i
i absolutely understand
um
i understand and sympathize with like
he's he's
he's doing the best that he can at his
job sure
yeah
it's almost like the hole in the the
death star that you're able just to
shoot through and blow the whole thing
up he's protecting the empire from those
little tiny holes almost well yeah so he
has exactly exactly so he has this kind
of like
um
self-aggrandized view of himself he's
got delusions of grandeur right he's
like well you know
i'm
even though he isn't part technically
the empire yet
he's like
i'm i'm the empire's presence here
because i do differently i i hold
everybody to a higher standard and like
this could be like
um
really important if we if we allow if we
allow certain things like this to happen
so
yeah he totally feels like he's a guard
dog
yeah and i i love the character for that
and thank you so much for your time
colin that we gotta wrap up but uh i
think everyone's gonna love andor and i
think everyone's gonna love cereal thank
you so much for your time thanks dude
thanks so much take care yeah so thank
you so much for your time today audrey i
appreciate it thank you so much thank
you